s'il est depuis plusieurs années
animateurs chroniqueurs hauteur et même
parfois humoriste michel cymes n'en
reste pas moins un véritable docteur
très présent sur les plateaux télé dès
le début de la crise il était en quelque
sorte devenu un porte parole médical
pour s'adresser aux français et relayer
les consignes sanitaires du gouvernement
mais finalement il a décidé de se rendre
utile directement sur le terrain en
répondant à un appel aux volontaires de
l'hôpital georges pompidou à paris
hôpital dans lequel il exerce toute
l'année mais en tant qu aux airelles
cette fois ci c'est au service de
réanimation que le docteur cymès a
décidé de prêter main forte aux équipes
une aventure qu'il racontait sur rtl et
le moins que l'on puisse dire c'est
qu'il décrit une situation qui ne
ressemble pas à l'urgence dans laquelle
semble plongé le pays j'étais dans une
réanimation où il y avait 15 malades
mais dans l'hôpital y avait 60 lits
qu'avait été qu'avait été ouverts et
finalement vous rendez compte d'abord
qu'il y ait un grand calme dans les
réanimations ans il précise toutefois
que ça ne doit pas être la même chose
dans les services d'urgence et que les
masques ffp2 commencent à manquer ce
témoignage de réanimation calme a de
quoi étonner pour certains cette
déclaration pourrait même dédramatiser
la situation autour de l'épidémie alors
pour vous une telle déclaration de la
part du docteur cymes et l irresponsable
alors est ce que cette déclaration était
responsable ou pas sophie koch non pas
du tout non mais c'est pas du tout est
responsable il décrit en fait c'est
sorti du contexte
il décrit l'ambiance qu'il ya dans le
service de réanimation donc on peut que
franchement le saluer parce que
effectivement il s'est mis au service de
réanimation lave pour aider les gens qui
sont débordés et en fait quand il dit
c'est très calme
ça veut dire que chacun sait exactement
ce qu'il a à faire et chacun garde son
sang froid
voilà comment c'est ça a été perçu d'une
manière mathieu mathieu il a dit chacun
que chacun une grande maîtrise de ce
qu'ils doivent faire partie si vos
pelles et sophie houle est on laisse les
autres il vous plaît les chéris aussi
fortement arrive à parler on va voir
matthieu delormeau dans sa tombe à voir
benjamin cas c'est à dire on va voir
gilles verdez sur cette déclaration dès
2006 mais si on aura également rené
malleville à nous donner
a tout de suite les p'tites boutures de
y'en a un qui a fait une sortie voilà
qui n'est pas passée inaperçue c'est
michel cymes voilà notre médecin voilà
du pas il était sur rtl on va écouter en
longueur ce qui a dit michel cymès a
longtemps le service de réanimation de
l'hôpital pompidou où il travaille
il est calme et bien sûr ça va à
l'encontre de ce que disent tous les
médecins dans les médias donc c'est vrai
que ça fait une petite polémique autour
de michel cymes regarder dans la
longueur ce qu'il a dit ou rendez compte
d'abord qui vient grand calme dans les
réanimations contrairement aux services
d'urgences probablement oula ça doit
être très speed là dans les services de
réanimation les gens sont très calmes
les patients sont tous comme on dit en
médecine technique et c'est à dire que
chacun est intubé et ventilé il ya des
seringues électrique des colonnes de
seringue électrique dont vous étiez
horaires ont tous été enlevés j'étais un
jeu je lui file un coup de main en
réanimation et vous apercevez que tout
se passe très calmement alors en même
temps il ya une note d'espoir c'est que
lierre alors je n'étais pas fière mais
j'ai eu leur animatrice au téléphone qui
m'a dit que pour la première fois il
avait deux lits qui était inoccupée donc
ça va bien dans le sens de ce qu'on
entend aujourd'hui c'est à dire qu'on
semble aller dans la décrue alors
mathieu mathieu est ce que t es ce que
tu es choqué par ce qu'il a dit est ce
que tu te trouves ça je suis plus que
choqué je suis atterré d'abord il
faudrait faire une compil jeux pan de
toutes les bêtises qui a dit michel
cymes depuis le début du confinement
mais ça c'est autre chose mais sinon
bien sûr je suis atterré c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui quand bien même ils
auraient raison dans son hôpital dit
supachai pas médecin mais aujourd'hui au
moment où on est en train de durcir les
conditions du confinement qu'on explique
aux gens que c'est la catastrophe
combattants donné cent mille morts que
certainement le président la république
va dire qu'on va de compte ils
poursuivent le confinement pendant
plusieurs semaines
son rôle au contraire je dirais pas si
vous nous faire peur c'est au contraire
véritablement de mobiliser les gens pour
contre le virus et lui il arrive la
fleur au fusil sur visiblement fait plus
souvent des médias que de la médecine
il arrive sur rtl non ça va c'est cool
c'est calme il ya des masses tout va
bien franchement mais s'il n'a rien à
dire au moins qu'ils se taisent parce
que là il fait du mal à tout le monde y
compris à d'autres médecins que je ne
citerai pas mais à qui j'ai parlé
aujourd'hui parce que je voulais pas
faire de bêtises et qui sont atterrés
par ce mec qui aujourd'hui n'est plus
médecin mais l'animateur non moi je vais
vous dire un truc et je vais le défendre
un peu c'est vrai que moi aussi moi j'en
janv aussi aussi à tous les gens qui
l'invitent ça veut dire qu'ils savent
qui fait de l'audience
donc tous les gens l'invite tous les
jours dans leur émission ils arguent les
martiens sert il oui mais voilà parce
qu'ils savent qu'en ce moment voilà bah
oui c'est ça donc comme c'est le seul
médecin un peu connu donc forcément ils
vont a rappelé michel cymes elle passe
constamment tout ce qui parle de
coronavirus mine de rien malheureusement
ça c'est cynique mais ça marche et ça
paie voilà donc il se dit on va
l'appeler on va le faire parler parce
que c'est le seul médecin qui est
référencée mine de rien par les
téléspectateurs
mais c'est vrai qu'à un moment je pense
que michel il devrait refuser un peu de
télé un peu de radio 1 gilles nommé
gérer la chine je ne suis même pas
d'accord avec vous parce que c'est
j'avais le grand vit dans c'est lui qui
vit dans ces médias il n'est plus
médecin il est dans la télé c'est lui
qui sollicitent encore récemment j'ai vu
qu'ils lançaient un magazine de presse
écrite ne fait plus que ça alors qu'il
fasse que ça mais qui laisse tomber la
rétine oui je suis passer un brouillon
réanimation ça veut dire il est allé
cinq minutes il en tire des conclusions
alors qu'il ya des médecins qui meurent
de ça il ya des personnels soignants qui
se dévouent et lui du haut de sa
renommée de son standing
il donne des leçons à tout le monde
c'est ça que je n'aime pas pour moi je
vous le dis franchement ça confine à
l'irresponsabilité c'est le
je-m'en-foutisme bigard qui passait
qu'en tire des conclusions a minima a
minima qu'il se taise
mais qu'il arrête de décrédibiliser le
travail de tous ses collègues qui sont
je trouve ça m'est vraiment abjecte
bravo gilles alors il ya alex et alex 5
infidèle alexandre que j'embrasse il me
dit il enchaîne boulette sur boulette
michel cymes christelle il m'insupporte
cymes ça va bien une maxime gagné je
trouve que la déclaration de simmel
c'est irresponsable
le problème cet animateur qui fait de la
médecine à côté c'est qu'il prend son
cas pour une généralité et il oublie en
tant que personnalité publique que c'est
un vrai porte voix en partageant voyez
ce genre de témoignage et rend pas
service aux autres dessins qui eux
passent leur temps n'ont pas derrière un
micro
mais à sauver des vies alors tant mieux
pour lui c'est calvot travaille mais je
ne crois pas que ce soit le reflet des
autres hôpitaux
moi moi moi soulève un lièvre aussi et
c'est vrai alors michel cymes oui c'est
vrai qu'il s'est fracassée par la
corporation des médecins est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est parce que il énerve il
est jalousé ou parce que ils en ont
marre de le voir sur les plateaux télé
être un petit peu leur porte parole
parce que c'est peut-être ça aussi
benjamin castaldi non mais juste je
pense qu'un c'est pas le porte parole
des médecins
moi j'ai rien contre lui mais c'est vrai
que objectivement il a fait un choix
très clairement de plus faire de
médecine et faire de la télévision est
chroniqueur animateur qui fait très bien
mais moi ce que je trouve très très
grave c'est que dans ce cas précis soit
ce que nous dit mais il y en eut
également est complètement faux quand on
lui dit qu'on est débordé dans le monde
dans la france entière qu'on déplace les
malades de gauche et de droite élu nous
dit c'est très calme alors soit on une
importe quoi il a raison et alors c'est
encore plus grave
soit c'est une grosse connerie et là
c'est inadmissible je suis désolé au
bout d'un moment il est peut-être
médecin il a été médecin mais là il est
un devoir un devoir de réserve et de
rétention des médecins
cyril franchement il connaît jamais
avoir ton avis rené malleville est
content tu sais qu'il y ait tout le
monde lui tombe dessus mais je ne
supporte pas ce mec parce que lui il a
été aussi le premier comme la majeure
partie du corps médical à tomber sur le
professeur ou quand on est allé voir cet
après midi à marseille
alors là je dis bravo pour ta je suis
willener thomas crown eastman 9001
lesueur
j'aimerais qui donne son avis le
président de république et qui va voir
où nuit comme on dit a dit qu'elle 15
jours a parfois ni les otites et les
maux de gorge
il sait qu à lui il a il a massacré nuit
et pape quand tu dis que tous les
docteurs qui passe sur un bateau le
matraque mais tous les docteurs qui
passent tous les plateaux qui matraquent
cimaises qui m'a pas qu'un code
frustrant ou parce que qui m'attaque aux
disettes tabac non mais nos colères rené
verrier rené rené juste pour te dire un
truc ils sont plus ils sont plus rangée
derrière cymes que il fracasse beaucoup
plus le docteur le professeur à moins
que je dédie ce qu'ils disent
dumas de s'y mettre ils ont fracassé
raoult et moi je suis content que ma
grande les talibans ont fait pas ce qui
va ressortir de cette réunion mais en
vain il a il a en fait à six sur le
piédestal où il fallait qu'il soit le un
des professeurs mondialement connu et
qu'on a la chance d'avoir braz et comme
le
pas écouté j'espère que géraldine
géraldine qu'on n'a pas entendu la ferme
là dedans y'a pas que ce qui m'est ce
qui crève l'écran moi j'estime
qu'aujourd'hui il ya 10 me mohamed qui a
crevé l'écran pendant cette crise il a
été exceptionnel il est là aussi en off
et ça il faut le dire parce qu'il est
sur le terrain il avec nous quand on a
un problème on l'appelle et moi je
voudrais dire que jenny mohamed a été
très très utile dans cette crise
sanitaire avec je trouve aussi beaucoup
d'humilité parce que des bleus s'était
trompé et voilà pour ensuite compliqué
de s'y mettre
attention quand même aux cimaises
bashing je pense qu'il faut quand même
un peu mettre ses propos en perspective
c'est à dire que oui au départ ils
étaient sur les plateaux télé n'était
pas dans les hôpitaux michel cymes et
donc forcément il raconté lui-même aussi
a dit que c'était une grippe est vous ce
n'est pas grave
l'anecdotique bon et là il est à
pompidou d'abord pour qu'ils nous ce
n'est pas tout les hôpitaux de france
y'a bon kid ou n'est pas forcément
représentatif et ensuite il dit que
c'était calme il dit que c'est calme
parce qu'en fait le système médical a
évolué ça fait maintenant de plus de un
mois donc il ya le président plus d'un
côté les colis de moins de l'autre on
s'est organisé il ya une méthodologie
qu'il n'y avait pas au début au début ça
a été un chaos
donc je pense qu'ils ont montré ce qu'il
veut montrer que le corps médical
maîtrise aussi l'attitude c'est ce qu'il
a besoin du de la méthodologie
alors on dirait on a on a la vidéo sur
europe1 ce dès le 10 mars sur 10 mars
donc de 2020 où il avait tenu à
relativiser le virus c'est ça qui l'a
été et non mais bien ses amis chefs
regardez vous êtes inquiet vous
personnellement non non seulement je
suis maintenant je veux absolument pas
inquiet bon c'est un virus de plus c'est
qu'on le dit souvent c'est une forme de
grippe cependant parfois dans certaines
années on a entre 8000 et 10000 morts
par an de grippe est ce que vous pensez
qu'à chaque fois que quelqu'un est
contaminée aux moeurs de la grippe on
fait une dépêche afp imaginez un peu le
nombre de dépêches qu'on aurait alors
mathieu rouler revenir et mourir mais
parce que géraldine quand bien même tu
raisons effectivement ce qu'il a dit
c'était de dire que ça se calme et tout
ça il a une responsabilité il est à
l'antenne
les gens qui écoutent ou pas forcément
comprend le second degré et tous à eux
tous qu'ils aient cause entendre les
jeunes qui sont chez eux c'est tient
visiblement c'est plus calme
il ya moins de monde peut-être dans des
hôpitaux c'est en train de se calmer on
peut relâcher un peu la tension et
sortir voilà le message qu'on reçoit
c'est quand même moment parle du sida et
conduit aux gens on ne peut-être en
train de trouver un vaccin non
protégez vous donc il a un rôle le rôle
c'est justement de faire attention à ce
que les gens écoutent et ne comprennent
pas mal ce qu'il dit et je comprends pas
ce rôle pour qu'ils arrêtent d'être
cabot et il faut qu'ils disent
maintenant qu'ils pensent vraiment aux
autres et puis je pense qu'ils devraient
vraiment vraiment se taire parce
qu'encore une fois socialiste à
l'occasion de faire une compil depuis le
début de tout ce qu'il a sorti mais
jared une pâture alliance et on perd du
poids
quant à la mi temps même quand il a dit
autour d'une table effectivement pardon
général bill je ne suis pas inquiet elle
va rien se passer on en a cent mille
morts et catastrophe
voilà pardon il met jamais de doute
quand il parle il sait tout parce qu'il
a un melon comme ça et quand il parle il
pense qu'il sait tout à l'heure le drama
disait il n'est pas porte parole des
médecins mais le problème c'est qu'ils
s'arrogent le titre de porte parole des
médecins
il n'a aucune respiration il a jamais
dit ça certes il ya une règle il ya une
règle journalistique
la règle c'est quand vous aller quelque
part on en tirait pas une leçon général
vous n'en tirez pas une règle pas émergé
gilles merci non mais oui je comprends
gilles on va on va écouter rené oui je
disais entre luis tu parles comme ça et
le mec qui parle de déconfinement alors
qu'on sait que m'accorde bien revenir le
dit vous nous raconter qu'on a peut-être
la nation et de deuil alors si un mois
extraordinaire qui nuit à la santé de la
population possède alors qu'il a assez
de parler tous neiges est qui qui laisse
parler les vrais professionnels de la
saleté je ne dis pas que ce n'est pas
correct je suis je suis d'accord et vous
n'y a pas que nous mais il fait partie
des sommités alors écoutons ces
jeunes-là et de charles a appuyé le
regretté jean raoux de charles a taillé
pour le savoir
alors que c'est mais qu'ils arrêtent de
parler à tous ceux qui parlent des codes
cinéma qui est qui minimise un petit peu
web doit bien d'aller animat l'autre
alors que en salle s'approprie scène sa
mort supplémentaire tous les jours et
guti ça il faut arrêter les conneries
comment tu veux pas que les mecs qui te
démonter livre et qui continuent à aller
courir
alors alors les cherry sur sur twitter
il ya plein de réactions
on n'a même pas besoin d'être à la
louche tôt pour comprendre que tout
n'est pas totalement calme michel cymes
les plus médecin c'est devenu un
animateur télé qui connaît la médecine
michel cymes corps est mieux de rester à
sa place c'est-à-dire confiné il fait
honte à tout le corps médical se
cimaises faut arrêter de donner la
parole il diplo de plus en plus de
conneries j'aimais bien michel cymes à
l'époque du mac de la santé avec marine
et maintenant il m'insupporte
il a oublié d'être médecin si mais c'est
vrai qu'il ya énormément voilà il était
dans le service de pédiatrie c'est
normal il ya des personnes et biens qui
nous dit ça je peux en bois que 6 mai
soit la personne préféré des français
alors il ya plein plein plein qui disent
à regarder on va voir le sondage est ce
que ces responsables qui a dit michel
cymes regardez moi pour son nom à 40
d'après quand même 42 % des gens qui ont
ce que voilà c'est pas irresponsable qui
a dit michel cymes donc voilà en tout
cas chez nous on est plus mesuré c'est
vrai que tout le monde lui tombe dessus
du cros était un aux téléspectateurs
sont plus mesurés et c'est plutôt pas
mal